hey folks this week we're going to
implement a simple qr code scanner in
our web app so the app is going to look
something like this we have an empty
video screen here where we can start
video capture
and then we can open up a qr code
and when we point the reader towards the
code we can see the url in this case
that's encoded in it so let's go ahead
and open up our editor and build this
for the actual qr code scanning we're
going to use this qr scanner library and
i've already gone ahead and installed it
in my project using npm
the project itself is a lit based modem
fusion project so we're using lit here
for the front end and we have a big
webpack build that runs uh runs the
front-end build we're also using
typescript but everything here should
work just this just the same if you're
using plain javascript
all right so if we look at what we have
right now i'll uh make this a little bit
smaller you can see we have the text
hello here and that's coming from the
template that we have here
now the first thing that we need to do
to use the qr scanner library is
imported so we're going to import the qr
scanner
from qr scanner and then what we need to
do next is we need to
import a
worker
so the qr scanner
uh has this separate worker file that it
loads on clients that don't have native
support for barcode scanning in the
browser
so by having this in a separate uh js
file it's able to only load it
if you actually need it so for those who
have a
modern browser with support they don't
need to incur the extra cost of of
loading this so we're using the file
loader webpack loader here to load this
javascript file into our dist folder and
i'm using ts ignore here because it
would otherwise
complain about this
all right so then let's go ahead and
scaffold out our template
the first thing that we want is a video
element and the video element if you
remember uh had a little bit of a shadow
and rounded corner so we're gonna use
some of these
same bottom utility css classes for for
that so we're gonna do a video with
rounded
small
and
shadow medium like this
it doesn't need to have a source but
what it needs to have is an id so that
we can get a hold of of the element so
we're going to call this
video
source like this
then we're also going to have a button
button button
that we can use for for toggling
we're going to get back to the button
here in in just a moment
all right so let's go ahead and save
that make sure that we have
everything
working
and yep here we go so we have
a rounded video element here with a
little bit of shadow and an empty button
right here
added some styles for it right here so
just giving it a max width so it's not
overly or really big here
all right so we've imported the qr
scanner so the next thing that we need
to do is initialize it so let's override
the first updated
callback inlet and at this point the
template has been stamped so we have
this video element already there
now we need a uh actual hold of it so
what we could do is do
uh just a plain uh
query selector so we could do this dot
render root
dot query selector
but there's actually a more handy way to
do that inlet so we can use this
query
decorator and say that we're we want to
get the element with the id
video source
and what we get from there is a
video
element
and the type here will be html video
element like this all right so now that
we have that element
and we are here in the first updated
callback
the first thing that we need to do is
configure this
scanner worker path so we'll do
qr
qrscanner.workerpath
is equal to
this qr scanner worker path that we
imported
and with that we're now ready to
initialize our qr scanner i'm going to
create a field here for
keeping track of that so i'm going to
call this the qr
scanner and it's optional
and the type will be
qr scanner like this
so that allows us to go here and say
this.qrscanner
is equal to a new
qr scanner and this takes in two things
so the first will be the video element
that we have
and the second one will be a callback
that takes in the
result whenever it finds a qr code
and here we can decide what we want to
do with it and what we're going to do
with it is save it into a
result so i'm going to do a
state here so
component state which will whenever it
changes trigger a re-render
and we're going to call this qr
result
and as
to start out it'll just be an empty
string but then when we get a result we
can say this dot
qr result
is equal to the result
like this
good all right so then i want to hook up
this button so that we can toggle the
the video off and on for that we're
gonna have another state here
for tracking if it's running
and by default it's not gonna be running
so
we start with it off
and then we create a method here that we
can use for toggling it
so we're going to say
toggle scanner
and here first of all we're going to say
this.running
is equal to the negation of the start
running
so we just toggle it and then
if we have a qr scanner so if this dot
qr scanner
qrscanner
make sure that we actually have one
before we start calling anything on it
so if
this is running
uh running
then what we want to do is call this dot
qr scanner
dot start
since we already toggled it here so this
is the
desired
state
and then
else we'll call this dot
qr scanner dot stop
like that all right so now this state
here will contain whether or not we're
running it and we can use it that in the
button here
so first of all we'll hook up the click
event
to
call that toggle so call this dot
toggle scanner
and
let's
arrange this a little bit make it easier
to read
and then we'll
actually use one of the built-in theme
variants here
so we're going to say that the theme is
equal to and then we can have a
check here that if this is running
then we'll say
error
it'll kind of look red and scary so
people know that
pressing it will stop and then otherwise
we'll say
primary it'll be nice and kind of
highlighted
and then inside the button
what we'll do is we'll
also
interplay here a value and again we're
checking if this is running
and if it is we'll say
stop
otherwise we'll say
start like that
then of course we
have this result here that we want to
display so
here below the button we'll do a
pre tag and in there we'll display the
result so we'll just say this dot
qr result
all right
go ahead and save
so now we see we have the start button
here because our we start up with the
running is equal to false and when we
click on this
the click here is
hooked up to the toggle scanner which
we'll call
qr code scanner.start
and this will ask if we give access to
the camera and sure enough we'll
do that
all right all there
and then we'll take a qr code put it up
to the camera
let's see
[Music]
there we go
and there we have a
link
i think qr support tier web application
has become really easy in the past few
years with these new web standards and
these high quality libraries
i hope this was a useful video for you
if you have any questions ask them in
the comments below and if you have any
ideas for new videos that you want me to
make let me know as well thanks for
watching and i'll see you in the next
one bye
[Music]
so
you